5 applicable
surtout une histoire d'amitié ses trois
copains qui retrouve une fille dont il
est amoureux lycée qui n'ont pas vu
depuis une vingtaine d'années et ils
replongent ça les fait replonger
immédiatement dans des réflexes
d'adolescents
pour moi il n'ya pas plus important dans
la vie que l'amitié yaxam intéressant
d'ailleurs
concrètement la carrière l'amour bien
sûr l'amour ça peut s'arrêter l'amitié
souvent
à aïn abid
mais avec toi chypriote électrique une
fille de 25 ans au plus tôt fin au maire
dont le clip est très exigeant en amitié
voilà qu'il essaie de recréer cet
univers-là et familiale comme ça dans
ses pièces et des voix la nourriture est
défini sur scène voilà à partir du
moment où on a des spectateurs on peut
se débrouiller seul avec les acteurs et
on peut à 5 donc nous l'émetteur faire
un spectacle est donné du plaisir et le
cinéma c'est vraiment un travail et
c'est à dire qu' aucun d'entre nous
n'existe les uns sans les autres et je
trouve que sur le tournage on sent
vraiment cette poésie action et ça c'est
pas innocent le roi lion des excuses
mais ça ne va pas très bien que tu veux
en venir
tiens ça sera les normes analystes
couper celle là ça montre vraiment
vraiment d'énergie
deux scènes
m
je